pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans son dernier discours le général de
gaulle a tenu à évoquer à nouveau le
problème algérien
il a réitéré son offre du 16 septembre
vers les dirigeants de l'insurrection
je leur d'écart que nous les attendons
ici pour trouver avec eux une fin
honorable au combat qui se traînent
encore réglé la destination des armes
assuré le sort des combattants
ensuite tout sera fait pour que le
peuple algérien est la parole dans
l'apaisement
la décision ne sera que la sienne
jamais peut-être les propos du général
n'avait été si écouter et cette fois de
tunis par la bouche de ferhat abbas la
réponse est venue au conflit et de
régler le problème
le gouvernement hongrois de la
république algérienne est le premier pas
est accompli d'autres restent à faire
mais l'espoir n'a jamais été aussi grand
[Musique]
l'inauguration du mémorial à la france
combattante dans la nuit du mont
valérien associés dans un même hommage
tous les combattants de la dernière
guerre ceux qui ont lutté sous
l'uniforme et les autres soldats de
l'ombre tombés sous les balles ou mort
dans un camp de déportation
tel était le sens de la présence de
l'urne renfermant les cendres de
déportés et des seize cercueils
contenant les corps de combattants
tombés sur le front ou dans la
clandestinité
en un les cercueils ont été déposés sur
chacun des 16 ou relief qui orne le
monument derrière le mémorial une crypte
creusé à même la butte des fusillés
attendait l'urne et les cercueils cette
cérémonie simple et grandiose devait se
prolonger le lendemain en plein jour par
la visite du chef de l'état à la crypte
le traditionnel pèlerinage du 18 juin au
mont valérien auquel le général de
gaulle n'a pas manqué depuis la
libération
revêtez cette fois un éclat particulier
[Musique]
et
le chef de l'état devait allumer aux
flambeaux à portée du tombeau du soldat
inconnu
la flamme du souvenir qui brûlera sans
fin au pied de la croix de lorraine le
voyage en extrême orient du président
eisenhower a donc été amputé d'une étape
c'est au milieu des ovations de la
capitale des philippines est arrivée la
nouvelle de tokyo priant le chef des
états unis d'ajourner sa visite au japon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la nouvelle manifestation à laquelle
s'était livré la veille les étudiantes
tokyo avait décidé monsieur kishi à
prendre cette décision
de fait la chaux lancée contre le
bâtiment de la diète avait été
particulièrement violent dix mille
étudiants de gauche s'étaient acharnés
contre les portes qui fermait l'enceinte
[Musique]
les grilles avait cédé et une bataille
rangée a peu de bâtons et de poutres
s'était engagée entre les étudiants et
les policiers
[Musique]
et
bilan de l'opération cinq manifestants
tués et plus de 500 blessés de part et
d'autre
[Musique]
les émeutiers avaient gagné malgré
l'élan d'un centre
le président eisenhower a été accueilli
à formose par le maréchal tchiang kaï
chek la réception au taipei fut d'une
chaleur extrême toute la population de
la capitale de la chine nationaliste
paraissait s'être réunis pour l'acclamer
mais à ce voyage triomphal une étape
mentez
à onze mois dans le cher l'orphelinat
des polices de france et d'outre-mer a
reçu la visite du directeur de la sûreté
nationale du préfet de police et de
nombreuses autres personnalités venues
inaugurer le nouvel interne
considérablement agrandie au cours des
dernières années cet établissement est
susceptible d'accueillir 300
pensionnaires
[Applaudissements]
bien que la plage de nice un site plutôt
farniente c'est pour d'autres raisons
que les directeurs de cinéma s'étaient
donné rendez vous sur la côte d'azur
un des thèmes de leur 15e congrès
présidé par monsieur trichet
les difficultés de l'exploitation en
raison notamment des taxes qui pèsent
sur elle
[Musique]
une des pièces maîtresses de
l'équipement du bassin de l'yser le
barrage de roseland double barrage
puisqu'il se compose d'un ouvrage du
type voûte surmonté d'un autre à
contreforts soit 145 m de hauteur
s'achève alors que la première mise en
eau vient d'avoir lieu
[Musique]
les journalistes sont venus visiter cet
important complexe hydraulique de l'edf
douze kilomètres et demi de galeries
amèneront l'eau du barrage à une
conduite forcée de plus de deux
kilomètres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le débit de cette conduite qui à plus de
trois mètres de diamètre permettra
d'alimenter la plus puissante centrale
de france lusine souterraines de la
bâtie pourra produire en effet un
milliard de kilowattheures par an
[Musique]
boire à francorchamps de la course
automobile la plus rapide d'europe le
grand prix de belgique la plus rapide et
aussi cette saison la plus meurtrière
deux morts un blessé grave tel est le
bilan de ce grand prix de belgique couru
à la moyenne fantastique de 215 à leur
part des bolides dont la cylindrée ne
dépasse guère celle de la voiture que
vous utilisez pour vos week-ends
l'australien jack brabham cooper numéro
2 domine de bout en bout l'épreuve
il est champion du monde et il tient à
affirmer qu'il est le meilleur pilote du
moment d'autant que le britannique
stirling moss considéré par beaucoup
comme le successeur de fangio et sur un
lit d'hôpital après l'accident dont il a
été victime au cou des essaims
c'est donc brabham qui gagne le grand
prix de belgique qui se prépare à
renouveler son bail avec le titre de
champion du monde
[Musique]
nouvel élu à l'académie française
rené clair est allé passé ses premiers
jours d'immortalité dans sa maison
proche de saint-tropez
[Musique]
avec cet amateur de pêche solitaire qui
est aussi l'auteur de tant de films
célèbres du million au silence est d'or
en passant par anne où la liberté c'est
le cinéma qui pour la première fois
entre véritablement sous la coupole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le monde des mauvais garçon possède
maintenant son dictionnaire modern art
go français rue de lappe nous sommes
allés à la recherche de l'auteur de ce
litre et du milieu pour essayer de lui
poser quelques questions monsieur
lebreton
oui est-ce que vous êtes prêts non
journal y messieurs les bretons vous
venez de publier un dictionnaire d'argot
est ce que vous pourriez nous dire à qui
veut des styles étaient tout va bien sûr
pour les cas pour les neiges de barboter
un peu d'habitants étaient barbus
éternité et lampre des barbecues ah oui
débrouiller exemple michel une débutante
cela devrait pas trop mal avec le juge
temps qu'il a fait lancé voie et qu'il a
promis lithium pour le joueur je crois
qu'on peut dire que la langue verte et
votre maternelle je suis déjà avant
d'avoir du poil sur le paiement piment
ah oui le nez ou parlant de l'est vous
avez une drôle de père de charme nos
chars ne cherchez pas ça veut dire
moustache aux images halo 2 matin ou
laisser pousser hors charmeuse en guidon
de vélo comme les malfrats de 14
vous avez les réponses mitec et ses push
à l'epo cera aux jo il aurait toutes les
langues et allégée prend ce but à zéro
au guide complètement le rongeur excusez
moi je vous en prie honfleur ah oui
téléphone
[Musique]